- Welcome, thank you so much
for joining us for Aid,
Geopolitics and Power,
our human rights back on
international aid agenda.
This is the fifth in a series
the Yale Development Dialogues
Economic Policy Lessons
from History, which is co-hosted
by the Yale Economic Growth Center.
The South Asian Studies Council
from the Yale MacMillan Center
and the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs.
I'm Catherine Cheney, and
I'll be your moderator today.
I'll briefly introduce the topic
and our panelists before we dive in.
But as I always reiterate,
these events are designed
to be conversational
and we really value your questions.
So if you're joining us on Zoom
please keep your questions
coming throughout in the Q and A
and we'll get to them as soon as we can.
So this topic is such a great fit
for our approach in this series,
Bringing Historians and
Practitioners Together.
When higher income countries get involved
in lower income countries,
whether through foreign aid
disaster relief or military intervention
they can justify their acts
by the goals to reduce
poverty, protect human rights
or advance their own interests.
And part of why we're having
this conversation today is due
to some recent structural changes
at major international
development agencies,
here in the US as well as in the UK,
marking shift in priorities.
So, yesterday was Samantha
Power's confirmation hearing
as president Joe Biden's
pick for administrator
for the US agency for
international development.
And as many of you know
the UK is department for
international development merge
with the foreign Commonwealth office
uniting development and
diplomacy in one new department
the Foreign Commonwealth and
Development Office, or FCDO.
So USAID and FCDO are two acronyms
you'll be hearing about a lot today
as some of the shifts we're seeing.
And we'll talk about what
lessons history might offer.
What lessons might history offer
as these agencies changed their structure
in pursuit of new priorities.
Our panelists are gonna look
at foreign interventions
of the past, their stated
intentions and real-world effects.
And they'll ask what this renewed emphasis
on human rights might mean
for poverty reduction in a
world of extreme inequality.
So joining us to discuss these topics
I'd like to introduce Melissa Dell.
She's a professor of economics
at Harvard University.
Her work focuses on long
run economic development
primarily in Latin America and Asia.
And she's conducted research
on how US military strategies
in Vietnam had a lasting impact
on that country's institutions.
You'll hear more about that
and some of her other research today.
Samuel Moyn is Henry R. Luce
professor of Jurisprudence
at Yale Law School and
professor of history
at Yale University and author
of "Not Enough Human Rights
In An Unequal World," very
relevant to today's discussion.
His areas of interest
in legal scholarship
include international law,
human rights, the law of war
and legal thought in both historical
and current perspective.
And two familiar names for
those of you who have joined us
before Rohini Pande is the Henry
J Heinz II Professor of Economics
and director of the economic
growth center at Yale.
Her research is largely
focused on how formal
and informal institutions
shape power relationships
and patterns of economic and
political advantage in society
particularly in developing countries.
And Rory Stewart is a senior fellow
at the Yale Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs
where he focuses on contemporary politics
in crisis and on international
development and intervention
in fragile and conflict affected States.
And Rory also served as the UK secretary
of state for international
development, DFID
which I mentioned earlier
where he doubled the UK investment
in international climate and environment.
So I'd like to start with Rohini actually
because Rohini was really
the person who put this
on the agenda for our
Yale Development Dialogues
as something to discuss, something
where history may offer lessons for today.
So Rohini, can you expand
on some of the trends you're seeing
in foreign aid development policy
and governance and the 21st century
particularly in a low and
middle income country context
and what does this demand,
or why does this demand
this question we're asking
today, are human rights back
on the international aid agenda?
- Thanks Catherine.
And thanks everyone for joining.
So let me just step back a couple
of decades to the start
of the 21st century.
I think it was a very heady time
for international development.
Economic growth in many parts of Asia
were fast reducing poverty,
and coming on the heels
of the Jubilee 2000 debt
relief, rich countries
were typically expanding
the aid programs so much
so that according to one
Brookings estimate by 2006
the amount of foreign aid available
in the world was sufficient
to bring every extreme
poor person up to the
threshold of a dollar 90 a day.
And alongside on the research
side in development economics
we saw a growing interest
in quantifying the impact
of development policies.
And this was exemplified by the rise
of the experimental analysis
of development projects.
But now the research has
flourished and was exemplified
by the Nobel prize in 2019 to
Banerjee, Duflo and Kremer.
I think the politics of aid
started taking a different turn
in the second decade of the 21st century.
So in 2013, both Canada
and Australia merged their aid departments
with their foreign offices.
And then Catherine, as you
mentioned in June of last year
Boris Johnson announced the merger
of the foreign Commonwealth
office with the Department
of International Development
to create what they described
as a new super department,
the Foreign Commonwealth
and Development Office.
And most recently
Samantha Power has been
formally given a table
at the National Security Council,
recognizing that the mission of USAID
alongside defense and
diplomacy is contributing
to national security.
And the common narrative
which actually goes
back to what Albert said
as Australian head at the time
of the merger was like, good
we're going to bring it
back inside the department
because you want
Australia's aid program to
be fully integrated into our
overall diplomatic effort.
We don't want a diplomacy going
in one direction and our aid
program going in another.
And so what we see today
is that rich countries
are increasingly explicit
about a desire to leverage
foreign aid for domestic goals.
And I think this raises this question
of what happens to the
world's poor and vulnerable?
And so this brings us today to
the start of the third decade
of the 21st century, which I
see as marked by two forces.
First, we're entering
a decade where perhaps
because of austerity
policies in rich countries
because of growing
inequality, rich countries
are extremely willing to see
development quite explicitly
as a situation of par, one way
they're going to use the resources
and the geopolitical
might to buy leverage.
But importantly, we are
also entering a decade
of democratic backsliding
in many parts of the world.
So we are seeing cases of elected rulers
weakening checks, and
executive park, tailing
political and civil liberties,
and undermining the integrity
of the electoral system very often.
And I'd say lower and higher
middle income countries.
And this is what really brings me
to the idea that I think we
need revisit the implications
of putting human rights on the table.
To date very few aid
agencies have led with it
but as we see growing
inequality, which makes it harder
for them to doll out just
cash transfers to the poor.
And as we see democratic
backsliding, we want
I think it's important to
ask what the challenges are
in putting human rights
as being central to development agenda.
Let me just say what I see
as the challenge for development
economists, which I am one.
I think that the challenges
that over the last two decades
we've seen a lot of
push on testing programs
in the social sector.
Of saying we want to put
resources where we can test it,
but how do you do, how
do you actually identify
how can you help liberal democracies
in the developing world?
You know, what institutions
can we support?
How do we actually test
whether that works?
And then, you know
how do we persuade rich
countries to put money there?
But instance, one example
where I think we do
have evidence is on
independent and credible media.
We have a lot of evidence
from actually field experiments suggesting
that they're held with accountability.
But to me, the open question
is how is this actually
going to become part of
what aid agencies do?
So over to Catherine with that.
- Thank you, Rohini.
And you set us up well by talking about
how rising inequality
may demand some change,
may put human rights back on the table
even if agencies haven't led with it.
And that brings me to a question for Sam.
So Sam, in your book,
you explore why the rise
of human rights over time
has not actually resulted
in social and economic
justice, but instead happened
alongside growing inequality
as Rohini described.
So can you expand on
that disconnect for us?
- Sure, to begin with,
thanks for the invitation.
And thanks for having me, I
look forward to learning a lot
you know, I'm, I would have said
that starting in the forties
the human rights agenda
and the development agenda
have been pretty disconnected
and remain so to this day,
it's really never
the twain shall meet rather than
the idea that human rights
were connected to development
or are now being put back.
In the 1940s, there was
the universal declaration
of human rights which came along
with some basic standards
in the economic realm
which we call economic and social rights.
Harry Truman in my country announced 0.4
which is conventionally dated
as the kind of origin of
development assistance.
The trouble is that the
ideologies of development
have, you know waxed and waned according
to different orthodoxies
amongst economists
and have been pretty tightly linked
to national security
agendas of giving states.
And that is likely to remain true
for as long as we can imagine.
And as far as I can tell,
there really hasn't been much connection.
Even once human rights began
to be taken more seriously
by the United States
and the United Kingdom
as foreign policy aspirations in the 1970s
there are a couple
of sets of exceptions
to that generalization.
There was conditionality, saying
that foreign aid had to be
kind of used as a carrot
to in incentivize bad regimes to treat
their peoples less badly.
There was also some, some
intersection between Jimmy Carter
and that president who kind
of brought human rights
to the global stage and
his development people
who began to talk a lot about basic needs.
You know, to come to your
question, my own, you know, thesis
has been that human rights name
a kind of sufficiency idea.
The basic entitlements in
that every human should get
on the basis of his or their humanity
you know, housing, food, health.
That is not the same
as a campaign against global poverty.
Although it's true that the
campaign against global poverty
of the last 40 or 50 years
has also been about a very
a flow of sufficient provision.
It's much lower.
Let's be honest, a
dollar and change a day.
The world bank standard
of express extreme poverty
that Rohini mentioned
is not the schedule of
economic and social rights.
More to the point human rights, activists
even once they began taking economic
and social rights more
seriously alongside free speech
and bodily integrity and things like that,
have been persistently
critical of development theory
for neglecting the much
higher floor of protection
that human rights are supposed to promise.
As of today I would say there's,
I wouldn't think of aside
from Samantha Powers appointment
and elevation that there's
there's a lot of prospect
for human rights coming to development.
I mean, that could be a rhetoric.
What it means is hard to say
and not on its power is not
even on the USAID website yet.
For one thing, the eradication
of poverty has mostly not worked
through any kind of human
rights agenda to date.
And it's been very spotty,
highly localized in,
on the surface of the world.
We've just lived through
a pandemic, you know
we're in the final stages of it
hopefully at least in the global
North, which has seen a lot
of reversals in the anti poverty agenda.
I would close by saying
it though, power is there.
The stated foreign policy
agenda of Joe Biden
and his people is actually to care most
about the American middle class.
And you see that I think most
graphically in a March, 3
speech that new secretary
of state Antony Blinken gave
in which he says that every little bit
of the reorientation of
American foreign policy
which must include what Samantha
Power is going to be doing
is really focused on making
sure that policymakers
don't forget Northern working classes
which led to Donald Trump,
you know, many think.
And so the, let's make
sure not to, you know,
get fooled by the hype
that we're on the brink of vast changes.
- Do you wanna close at that, all right
we'll make sure not to
get to get into the hype
or at least we'll break down
whether this is rhetoric
or whether this is real.
And I took note of something Sam said
which I think really captures one
of the themes we're getting at here.
That a flow of sufficient
provision does not
equal social and economic rights.
And that development
theory tends to neglect
the much higher floor
of protecting that human
rights are meant to promise.
And so we'll see if there's change
but Sam seems unconvinced
that we're on the brink of major change.
And I think that's great.
We're gonna get into perhaps some debate
among our panelists a bit later.
But I wanna go ahead and bring Melissa
into this conversation.
Melissa, your research has focused
on how foreign intervention
affects development
across the range of geographies.
And I'd love for you to expand
on some of your research in Vietnam.
Those who may have seen
the promotional video
for this webinar might
have a preview of that.
Your research in Vietnam,
as well as Mexico
and what lessons from those
experiences seem most urgent
and relevant today?
- Yep, thank you so much.
And thank you also for
inviting me to be here.
So I wanna start by picking up
on a point that came up before
when Rohini was talking,
which is this idea that
we've seen in recent years,
kind of geopolitical objectives
and development aid objectives
moving closer together and
becoming more intertwined.
And I'd say that if anything
like that's been the
norm and maybe, you know
like in the period after
the cold war, you know
people were a bit less anxious
about those geopolitical
objectives and that relaxed a bit.
But I think that that's changing now
and kind of with the rise of China
and that it's not an accident
that this is happening again.
And so if you go back
and you think about the
policies in the 1960s
with John F. Kennedy, the
Alliance for progress, you know
his other kind of
development aid, priorities
those were very closely linked
to the fight against
communism into the cold war.
And I think that that's
just the norm and, you know,
to tie this back and to the question
and to my research and, you
know, so broadly speaking
we can think about kind of two
different schools of thought
about how the US and
other rich countries kind
of achieved their geopolitical objectives
in low-income countries.
And so again, if we go
back to the cold war
there was this very kind
of prominent view popularized the most
by like Walt Ross out who was an economist
and also Lyndon Johnson's
national security advisor
that you know, communism is
this disease of the transition
from being an agricultural
to an industrialized society.
And, you know, the US needed
to stop poor countries
from succumbing on, you
know, to that disease.
And there were two general ways to do it.
And so what Ross Stout
and what others advocated for
is you do that through force.
You make people realize
that it's gonna be extremely costly
if they go against, you
know, the non-communist state
in the context of the cold war.
And the other view which
was actually much less sort
of prominent historically.
But some people did argue for it is
that you have to give
people meaningful incentives
you know, to support a
democracy or to support
a non communist state through,
you know, through the state
providing them things that
are meaningful to their lives
you know, schools,
health clinics, security
things like that.
And so this is a question that I studied
in the context of the Vietnam war,
where the objective of the
US and the Vietnam war.
It wasn't so much, you know
stamping out specific
and surgeons per se, but
it was creating a South
Vietnamese state that would stand
as a bulwark against communism
after the US withdrew.
And to have that people
have to support the state.
And so they're very explicitly
kind of social scientists,
economists, political
scientists, et cetera
they thought about like,
well, how do you get people
to support the state and
sort of the dominant view
and what the US overwhelmingly
pursued was to do that
through overwhelming firepower.
You make it extremely costly
for them to go against the state.
And I think like very much a game theory
was influential kind of in
how people thought about this,
and just kind of the
general intuition that
if you go out and you'd
be really aggressive
that they're gonna back down.
And so, you know, the US
dropped many times more bombs
on South Vietnam than were
dropped in all of Asia
and all of Europe from world war II,
just an overwhelming amount of firepower.
And in our paper
we're able to exploit exogenous variation
from an algorithm that
the US use to target
these bombings to show
that that policy backfired.
That when they bombed
civilian areas that rather
than people saying, Oh, like,
I better do what the US wants.
And what's out the South
Vietnamese government wants
I better support this state.
And so they wouldn't join the vehicle
because they were angry,
you know, rightfully so.
But that wasn't like, you know, that
wasn't the only thing
the US did in Vietnam.
That was the dominant perspective.
But an interesting context
that we also look at
is that the US Marines by and
large took a different kind
of perspective on fighting the war.
And so the US Marines have this sort
of long history of being like
the US Imperial police force.
So to say, like in the Caribbean,
and, you know, I'm sure
that they did lots of horrible
human rights abuses there
but compare that to the army.
Who's kind of, you know,
founding motives were just
to line up and shoot as
many people as possible.
It's like a different perspective.
They worked a lot more
closely with locals.
They did development aid,
and that's what they pushed into Vietnam.
And so we look at this area
that was commanded by the Marines
versus very nearby places that
were commanded by the army
the Marines built schools,
they built health clinics.
They work closely with locals.
And in those areas you
see far yet, you know
less attacks on the US, you see
people are South Vietnamese citizens,
and public opinion data
are more supportive
of all levels of South
Vietnamese government, you know,
and the US they actually see public goods
actually being provided, you know
so we can't say, well,
would it have been better
if the US just didn't get
into this conflict at all?
You know, which there's
a strong argument for
but like conditional
kind of on being there
and finding this conflict
this kind of development
aid approach appears
to be much more effective on,
and then kind of to tie this
idea into the president.
I don't think that this is
something that is limited
to the cold war that is limited
to foreign intervention, per se.
There's just this broad idea of like
you have places that are not really
within the control of the
state, and this is very common.
Like, how do you bring
those places, you know
under the control of a state?
And this was also like what I looked
at in Mexico at the
war on drugs in Mexico.
And so this is not exactly
foreign intervention though.
Obviously foreign policy
is a big motivator
for the war on drugs.
And that is kind of, that's another kind
of rich country policy that
has had enormous implications
on for the developing world.
But I look there at, you know, crack down
on the drug trade and it shows
something that's, you know
a little bit reminiscent
of what we found in Vietnam
which is that the state comes in
they cracked down on the drug
trade in a given location
and that weakens the
incumbent and leads, you know
their rivals to come in and try to fight.
And since the state actually
has fairly limited capacity
it just unleashes these drug wars
and then people just
take the drugs around.
And so, you know, it's not
as if you know, this is
I think the goal of Mexico
was to get the drugs
to like go through the Caribbean,
but in the end that didn't happen.
They just took other routes
in Mexico and it kind of
unleash this violence.
And, you know, of course the state side
of it is not the only side.
We also show that when young
men lose their jobs due
to trade shocks from
China, they're also more
likely to go join drug gangs
and that creates violence.
And so there's an economic
component as well.
But in general, I think that it's kind
of reminiscent of the
same debates that came up
in the sixties and seventies, you know
so I was talking with, you
know, some officials in Mexico
and there was a group,
like an influential group
that was really heavily
advocating, like, okay
let's not just fight
this on, through sending
in the military, like,
let's give development aid.
We know in some of these places
there's not other job opportunities.
People don't trust the state
because they've had a bad experience.
Maybe the state can come
in and build infrastructure
and that's useful for creating jobs.
And, you know, they
almost got that program
and they almost got that
program off the ground
but then somebody else
came in and was like
wait a minute, like,
we're national security.
Like we don't do development aid that's
for the social development ministry.
Like, what do you mean?
Like we go in and we show
them who's in charge.
And I think, you know, to tie
it back into the beginning
and about kind of the most
pressing lessons, you know,
at least you know, I'm not an expert
on international diplomacy
but people were arguing
that we're kind of moving
into this phase of kind of,
you know, a new cold war
something like it with
China, where China is rising.
You know, they're taking kind
of a very aggressive stance
on the global stage and, you know
how's that gonna play out?
And in the kind of linking this idea
of like development aid with diplomacy
like the reality is that
diplomacy is just always
gonna be, you know, that like,
and like the security
interests are gonna be
like the number one objective.
But is there a way to do
that where, you know, even
if it's like grossly
inadequate development aid,
that's you know, getting
people's income up a few cents
or something that's better
than going and like, you know
dropping bombs on them or, you
know, encouraging, you know
a government to take
on like a violent conflict
against people, right?
And so I think
that it is actually a
potentially promising thing
that these objectives
kind of get integrated.
And how do we think about, you know
our influence on the
global stage, not just
through being the kind of
aggressive, the most aggressive
you know, country around, but
also giving people, you know
incentives to want to support the US
or to wanna support,
you know, our objectives
through a development
aid and other policies.
- Thanks, Melissa, really
helpful examples in terms of
when we look at this connection
between development and
diplomacy and defense,
how has it worked use incentives
versus force over time?
And I'm glad you mentioned China.
I hope that's something we can return to
when we all jump into
discussion in a little bit,
and we have some great
questions coming in.
So just a reminder to those
of us, those of you joining us
on zoom, please keep
those questions coming.
I'm excited to get to some of these,
but I wanna bring Rory into this.
So Rory, we mentioned earlier, some
of the changes happening
with foreign aid in the UK,
that aid agenda has undergone
quite a transformation
over the past year, and it's
still changing it seems.
So I'd like to ask you what
does this mean for the UK's work
on human rights and how has that changed
as a priority from when
you led DFID to now?
And what do you expect next?
Oh Rory, you're on mute.
- First thing, first thing to understand
is that we are going through in the UK
what is a pretty natural
evolution, I guess
for every country and has
some implications in US.
Which is that DFID was set up
with a very idealistic structure.
So in the late 1990s
the idea was that UK
would commit to spend 0.7%
of its GDP on international development.
And it would create this
completely independent apartment
of government cabinet level department
which would have basically nothing to do
with the foreign service
or the ministry of defense.
And it was set up by law that
it could only spend money
in order to tackle extreme politics.
And this was deliberately done
because obviously the people working
for it and setting it up,
wanted to try to protect it
against any of the other temptations.
So it was almost the purest possible kind
of incarnation of a dream of development.
It was also set up so that there
could not be any confusions
with national interests
that were very, very
illegal actions to stop
people using this money
to try to procure British goods
to do anything of the sort.
From the beginning, this
was an enormous problem.
And a problem that the people working
for DFID probably did not
fully anticipate or understand.
They staff the department with many
many people who would found
anonymous or came out of NGOs.
And they, at some level, people were very
very reluctant to get
involved in the conversation
with the public or other politicians
about what this money
was being used to do.
And the scale of money you're talking to,
so by the time I was running DFID
we had a budget of about 20
billion US dollars a year
totally unrestricted, right.
I had no control at all
about really how that money was spent.
Because it was almost impossible
for any other government
department to get its hands
on that money.
In addition, austerity was taking place.
So I remember this
extraordinary meeting that I had
with Rohini when I just be moved from my
I think my second place to DFID.
I've been moved to run UK prisons
before I went back to DFID again.
And I moved from this enormous
office that I had in DFID,
this tiny local by it's
in a concrete building.
I was sitting with Rohini.
That morning, I had signed
off on, I think something
like $200 million for an
education program in Ethiopia.
And that afternoon I'm sitting
with Rohini now as the
Minister for Prisons, realizing
that we were gonna have to get rid
of the bottom five floors of
our office in central London
in order to try to save, I
think, nine or 10 million pounds
having just signed off on
200 million that morning.
And this of course meant
that enormous problems
would then raise about
what on earth was happening
with this money, right?
When the public began looking at it.
And you can think of all
the kinds of problems
because we experienced them.
And of course, this is
relevant for Joe Biden.
This is relevant to Jake Sullivan.
This is relevant for
Smith because of course
what Jake Sullivan has been
writing about a great deal
is the sense in which US foreign
policy cannot be detached
from what people, us citizens think.
I mean, it's been for 60, 70 years
really an elite occupation.
People have tried to
remove foreign policy away
from public opinion.
But in the end you have to justify it.
You have to answer some
basic question, right?
So you say that you're
eliminating global poverty.
How are you doing?
You know, what have you been
doing it for the last 40 years?
Where are your success stories?
You are working with this regime.
So let's just run through some
of the problems in Britain.
And then I'll just flip
it back to human rights.
But what were the practical problems?
We were giving a hundred
million pounds a year, to India.
Why, because India had
a lot of poor people
but we then discovered
that India was giving
exactly a hundred million
pounds a year in development
aid to Afghanistan.
Right, so the British
public has being asked
to give a a hundred million
pounds a year to India.
India is just giving all
that money to Afghanistan.
Well, from the point of
view of DFID employees
there was no problem with this,
because there were people living
in extreme poverty in Northern India.
So they couldn't see why
anybody found this a problem.
Or I would go into see
president Kagame in Rwanda.
And I would talk about human rights
the big human rights problems, in Rwanda.
And he would laugh and say
you don't care about human rights.
And I'd say, what do you mean,
I didn't care about human rights?
And he'd say, "Quite explicitly
in this meeting, well
you've just given us another
a hundred million pounds
of development aid.
So if you cared about humans rights,
you wouldn't do that, would you?"
These conversations are
happening all the time.
That's before you get onto the
things that you can imagine.
Scandals about corruption,
scandals about waste,
huge anxieties and bursts
which haven't yet hit the United States.
But I promise you they are coming
about the amounts of money
that people are spending
and are paid running
development agencies, right?
Your average person in Britain,
who's being asked to give an on average
your average British citizen
would have had to give
if you look at the compare
the amount of money we were giving
to the population about $500
a year towards this, right?
So imagine maybe you've got to learn
that you're giving an effect
2, $300 a year towards this.
It's very, very difficult for you
to understand why somebody
running a big charity
is earning hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year.
Because you think that this is being done
as a sort of voluntary
charitable activity.
You're imagining what's happening
in international development
in terms of, you know
what's happening in your local community.
Somebody working on a very low income
out of a great sense of idealism.
And suddenly you're having
to confront the fact
that these are organizations
with contractors
who are poverty experts
earning $1,500 a day
doing poverty alleviation in
somebody else's country, right?
Now, let me just tie this
back to human rights.
So we can now get into
more of a conversation.
Fundamentally, the question
around human rights is how
on earth do you as the United
States or the United Kingdom
or indeed anybody, develop
country strategies?
How do you decide whether
or not you are going to,
for example give money
to Rwanda and Ethiopia,
why do I choose them?
I choose them because they are
amongst the most brutal
authoritarian regimes in Africa.
And they are also
the greatest development success
stories in Africa, right?
They are the places that
development economists
are really excited by it.
They're almost the only
two countries in Africa
which people really get huge excited
by because they've achieved
seven, 8%, even nine
10% growth over the last decade or so.
And what sort of leverage do you have?
Because somewhere implicit
in this conversation is
an idea that people had,
that you could improve the
human rights performance
of these countries by using the carrot
of development aid as the way to do it.
But in practice that almost never works.
And I saw it, and I'll finish
with these two examples.
I saw it in South Sudan where my colleague
and friend Mark Green,
who was running USAID
when I was running DFID,
went in to see Salva Kiir.
So horrible civil war
happening in South Sudan,
and the present of South Sudan Salva Kiir
deeply implicated an
incredible brutal massacres
and horror and stealing
our development assistance.
So extended food aid, and it's stolen.
So the borders and
people being burnt down..
And Mark Green said, look
if you continue behaving like this
we will cut off the development program
and Salva Kiir effectively
shrugged and said, fine.
You know, you want to take the money away.
That's your problem.
If you want lots of poor people to start
that's your problem, take the money.
I don't care.
Right, and again, in Tanzania, Magufuli
president Magufuli who
the great anti COVID
campaigner who's anti COVID campaign came
to an unfortunate end a week ago
refuse to take a call from the US state.
The US ambassador refused
to go in and see him.
He declared the US ambassador
persona, kicked him out.
And the US government
was effectively forced
to come back again into
Tanzania a couple of years,
basically with a billion dollars worth
of development assistance
to try to buy their way
back into the good graces
of a relatively small country
in Sub-Saharan Africa.
Because the assumptions that the US
and the UK have about power,
that somehow they can use
even rather large sums of money
as ways of changing the behavior of people
in these countries completely
underestimates the power
of nationalism state sovereignty,
the actual incentives
of people who are in political
power in countries ranging
from Yanmar through to
Tanzania, and really calls
into question the extent to
which it is actually possible.
Now, even if it would desirable actually
possible to use development assistance
as a lever for transforming
attitudes to human rights.
Okay, enough for me.
- Thank you, Rory.
So Rory just talked
about some of the limits
of development aid as a
carrot, or in fact saying it
doesn't work.
Are there many examples of it not working?
So I'm curious before I ask
some questions, I haven't get
to questions from our audience.
Do any of our panelists
wanna react to that or react
to anything else you heard,
where you might be on the edge
of your seat and have something to say?
Otherwise, we have some
great questions coming in
but I wanted to give
you all an opportunity.
Okay, so I'm gonna go
ahead and ask a question
that Sam posed or turn it into a question.
Sam basically said, the
question we're asking today,
are human rights back on the
international aid agenda?
Might not be the framing he would use
and that he's not quite
sure we're really on the
brink of major change.
I'm curious, what do our
other panelists think?
Is this a critical turning
point or not necessarily?
- Let me throw a second
and then come to people.
It seems to me that part of
this needs to be understood
in terms of competition with China.
And in particular in attempt by the Biden
and Johnson and others
to try to frame democracy
as an alternative to
authoritarian regimes.
And so in so far as human
rights gets back onto the agenda
I suspect a lot of it will be
through the prison of
trying to create a coalition
of inadvertent comments democracies,
in this new form of competitional
conflict with China.
But again, and I think I'd love to hear
from Melissa on this,
the experience of the cold war suggests
that although you may talk
about creating democracies
as the alternative to
your authoritarian rivals,
in practice you end up with cooperating
with people who aren't democracies at all.
- I'm glad we're returning
to the topic of China,
thoughts on that, Melissa?
- Yeah I mean, I think that
it's sort of a matter of degree
in terms of like what you're
doing and what you can achieve.
And so I, you know, I agree
that there is no, you know, like
whether you're coming at it
from the side of kind of the US
or the Soviet union during
the cold war, there's not
like neither kind of group
has a great track record
of being able to essentially
like force countries
to take on their model.
Whether you look at the
Soviet Union in Afghanistan,
the US in Vietnam, you know
there's maybe some success stories
like Parma comes to mind
from the perspective
of the US but I think it just sort of like
it depends on what you wanna achieve.
And I agree that if the
goal was to, you know,
you have some brutal
dictator and you think
that with the carrot
of this development aid
you're gonna change his policies.
Like that's just not realistic
and that's just not going to happen.
But, you know, there
have been like, you know
a series of studies looking,
you know, in conflict zones
and Afghanistan or Pakistan,
the Philippines looking
at the role of the
development aid programs.
And I'd say the literature is kind of
like a little bit mixed, you know
but there's some evidence
that these programs
at least it's gonna depend on the details
but there can be success
in terms of giving people
like an alternative besides
supporting the Taliban.
So I think that when you
think about things on kind of
like a more granular level,
as opposed to, you know
looking at political change
at the national level
but then there can be
kind of more examples
where things come sort
of closer to achieving
what the objectives are.
But I agree that I don't
think we really know
how this works.
We understand a lot more
about what you would
need to do when a world
without politics to alleviate poverty,
then how you actually do that
in a political context
where there's people
who just don't care, actually
benefit from the fact,
that lots of people are living in poverty.
- Thanks, Melissa, and well
put in terms of how this works
in a world without politics
versus a world with politics
which is part of the value
in bringing academics and
practitioners together.
Sam, I see you wanted to jump in.
- It's so interesting.
I just, you know,
I'm very averse to the general framing
that we're entering a
new cold war with China.
I think it's, you know, disastrous
that we're allowing Donald
Trump to define, you know
our own relationship to this
coming year of geopolitics.
Not least since it seems
really hard to think
about the current Chinese state as similar
to the Soviet union in its broader agenda.
I mean, of course it is a
communist state formally
but it's not like the global
peasantry or its, you know
its leaders as being
set on fire by communism
or as an ideological matter or
by neo-Confucianism or whatever
you think China represents.
And, you know, we'd have
to get into like really
serious debates about
what China's, you know
outward facing politics
really are to figure
out what kind of threat
they pose, unless by threat.
You mean that they're getting
really rich really fast.
Of course, it's absolutely true.
And Rory's right about this, that
they're repressing at home
and I think human rights
are of considerable use in thinking about
what kind of China policy
Western States ought to
have, you know, to get
the weaker some attention,
although probably not much help.
It's very different to
suppose that the rise
of China represents that kind of new era
of competition globally, where
we have to like, you know
decide which despots were gonna prop up.
Whether with Melissa were,
you know, on the brink
of bombing, a lot of
peasants into, you know
capitalism that does, it doesn't seem
like we're anywhere
close to that situation.
- And so-
- Please Rory, please.
- Just, I mean, look my
sympathies are with you
on this, but I think
that one of the oddities
about the way that
particularly departments
of defense think is they
like to have an enemy
when they frame strategic
security policies
they do these things.
So Britain, for example
has just published its
integrated security review.
And the whole review is about
a shift to the Indo-Pacific,
it's that it's moving
out of the middle East
and Africa trying to and
a loss of the framing
around the G10 meetings are
also around democracies.
And in so far as we
can read the tea leaves
of the recent Lincoln
meetings with the Chinese
this has becoming more and more important.
So I think it's possible
for us to agree with you.
Some this may not be a
very sensible thing to do
but I think empirically there's a lot
of evidence that there's huge temptations
from the national security
establishment in Europe
and in the United States
I think increasingly
framing level international
policy of the next 20 years.
- There's no doubt about that.
I mean, I can see that entirely,
but that they're not actually
the political leadership,
they're supposed to be subordinate to it.
But no you're of course you're right
that these forces are active and you know,
the national security
expertise being quite far
beyond militaries is
always seeking enemies.
As you say, I think
the real dilemma is how
to free development assistance
from that kind of politicization,
but also recognize
that the track record
is grim for linking it
to a kind of democratization
and human rights strategy.
First that it's not clear
that these Western States
don't in the end often side
with despots for the wrong reasons.
But also when they side against them
they don't make that much of a difference.
So the you know, I'm just
kind of suggesting that
if we detach that discussion
from the geopolitics
of standing down China,
we might kind of, you know
make a little more progress,
but of course, you're right
that we may not have a choice.
Given the lots of interests are leading us
towards this new cold war framing.
- Let me just jump in
with one question I think
which is on moving from
thinking about bi laterals
to thinking about
multilateral institutions.
And maybe the, when we
think about the human rights
perhaps the one to really bring
on stage is to think
about the United Nations.
I think in the 1990s
what we did see was the UN
played quite an important role
in terms of human rights
by entering the stage
when a newly independent countries coming
out of conflict for writing constitutions.
So we saw a lot of UN push
that the one that I'm the most familiar
with is on gender quarters.
So I think in country, after country
the UN pushed very hard
to have gender quotas put
in place instance in Rwanda.
And it was accepted by the
countries at that point in time
because very often women
will say less implicated
in conflict.
And so they were more willing
to have them be part of it.
And so, you know, certainly
one reason why in Rwanda now
it's a majority female parliament,
and we can debate whether
or not had it had a role,
but that that's one place
where I think the UN, which
in many other places, you know
doesn't have much money
or much influence was able
to strategically make a
difference by entering
on constitution writing.
So I'd be curious if we sort of see places
where perhaps maybe less bi laterals,
but more multi laterals could enter.
I think the flip side of
the UN is the World Bank,
which for the longest time said
it would not engage with
politics or governance.
It was very explicit about
it, but it seems to have more
recently been willing to start
thinking about it perhaps
through a more anodyne
term, like state capacity.
- Very quickly on that one.
But I mean, I think the,
you are actually right.
There's something very interesting
that you've pointed out that in Rwanda,
because this a paradox, isn't that?
On the one hand they've achieved
these remarkables statistics
and it was a female
participation parliament.
On the other hand, it is an intense
the authoritarian regime, which
has included assassination
of political opponents and
all forms of oppression.
So I think this may be
rather interesting theme
that could be pursued if we
had more time about the ways
in which conversations about
diversity and conversations
about what we traditionally called liberty
maybe heading in different directions.
In other words
that it would be possible
to create a regime.
And indeed I think that
beginning to emerge
which seemed to resemble
our images of diversity
without bringing the kinds of
benefits in terms of liberty
and maybe ultimately in terms
of stability and peace that
you would have anticipated.
- I'll just add on to that,
you know, I think Rohini
has asked a really important
question, but there's
in a way history to this present
divergence that Rory notes.
I mean, just to cite one example,
the authoritarian feminism
of someone like Princess
Ashraf of Iran of Iran
before her brother's
government was toppled,
which the Western power
supported of course.
And that was another example
where there, there was a lot
of talk about the regimes feminism
and she in particular
talked about a lot about it
at global UN human rights conferences,
the world over notably in the
Tyronn conference at in 1968.
But of course that didn't,
that the Iranian regime
was bringing a liberty generally.
And of course it
eventually paid the price.
- I wanna bring in a few
questions from our audience
and keep them coming.
Although I know we're running out of time,
but there's some fantastic questions here.
And we were kind of moving
around geographically
in these questions, but
this is a question related
to central America and migration.
So Allen Masca asks
president Biden says that US
and Central American
countries must address
Central American sources,
root causes of migration
which are extreme poverty and violence.
There can be no US national
security, democracy
human rights, and freedoms at
home until poverty eradication
and human rights uplift
people's lives everywhere.
Can speakers comment on a
possible human rights agenda
for Central America?
So any thoughts on that?
Then we have questions moving us
around other parts of
the world to follow, but-
- That's like, I'll just
bring in a point that kind
of like indirectly addresses
this and that, like, you know
this conversation seems
like pretty pessimistic
but I think it's actually
just realistic, you know
reflecting all the
difficulties of going, you know
into a foreign country and
changing the equilibrium there
you know, whether it's
eradicating extreme poverty
but also the politics of it.
And that ties in a lot.
And that's certainly
true in Central America,
but it's also true that
like we can think about like
are there domestic policies
that would have a huge impact
on places like Central America
on the developing world?
Because ultimately like what we'd,
like the world's like connected.
And so like in the case of Central America
I mean like one obvious
thing is the war on drugs.
And we know that it's completely
like failed in the US I
mean, like, it's not that,
like it had no effect
essentially like on, you know,
the number of Americans that have problems
with drug addiction and just like fixing
that own failed policy at home, even
if we can never convince
the American public
to care one bit about central America
just coming up with a more
effective, you know, strategy
like for drug addiction, you
know, would have an affect.
I know like a lot of the damage is done
and there's also, you know
there's also other things
at play just a very weak state on
and that like kind of wanders
into the realm of things
that we don't really know
how to fix, but, you know, just things
like that are another huge
point for Central America.
And if we wanna talk
about extreme poverty is climate change.
And so when you look at predictions
for like what the climate
is gonna look like in 2100,
Central America looks like
uninhabitable virtually.
I mean, because it's already very hot
and that's going to just
get very much more extreme
and this is another thing I've done work
on about how the impacts
of extreme temperature
are much more severe on poor countries.
And part of it's because
they're hot, but also just
they have kind of less
coping strategies at hand.
And, you know, I think that
there's also a growing sense
that climate change is bad for
the US, it's bad for Europe.
I mean, look at California being on fire.
So maybe like, you know,
like even if we think
that there's not a huge
amount of hope for these kind
of foreign aid like development
assistance objectives,
if we just like more modest there
but you realize just by
fixing some of the policy,
like, you know, getting
policies more right.
Like, and going back to
the, like the Biden thing
about like, well, can this help
the middle class in America?
Like, you know, maybe some
of these policies, like, yes
they can and they can be
spun in that way, but like
they have the potential to have an effect
that is much kind of larger
than whatever, you know
in the grand scheme of
things fairly easily,
like, you know, development aid.
So I'm certainly not saying
to abandon development
assistance or, you know,
the like these objectives
to have like, you know state
capacity as Rohini said
which is kind of how it gets
framed, like in the context
of Central America or, you
know, development assistance.
But I think that, you know,
like as we've talked about
they don't have a great
track record and maybe
like another perspective
on it is that by, you know
fixing some of these problems at home,
we're less likely to just
have this collateral damage
or go and be, you know,
propping up dictators
during these other things
that have horrible effects.
- Sam, I see you wanted
to jump in quickly.
- Yeah, no, I think the
question is really well taken
because apart from the
let's say difficult optics
that Joe Biden faces to the
extent he has to, you know
have exclusionary politics at the border
of any kind he has, you know
and liberals generally have
a difficulty of figuring
out how to connect the
short-term and the long-term.
So in the short term with
folks at the border border
there is a human rights
obligation minimally
to hear and grant, you know,
legitimate asylum claims
even when migrants are economic, migrants
and converting their claims into the kind
of claims that can be taken seriously.
But in the longterm,
it's not clear to me that
the global anti-poverty
agenda is ever going to
by itself alleviate the
drivers of migration.
And this is an opportunity
for me to introduce
like the main theme of my
recent book, which is a contrast
between these ideas about
sufficient provision
whether generous or ungenerous
and this very different idea
of a more egalitarian living standards.
It seems like dubious to
me that once a peasant gets
above a dollar in change a
day, he'll decide not to move
to the United States if he can get there.
And so I totally agree
with Melissa about the
looming climate refugee crisis
but quite apart from it, if
we don't focus our development
thinking on greater equalization
over the long-term of standards of living,
we will have economic migration
for as long as we can see.
And then the attendant
border politics that you know
are cross Mediterranean
politics that we've seen
everywhere in the world in recent decades.
- I wanna bring in one more question
and it has to do with China
and I was hoping to bring it in earlier
but I think I'd like to broaden the frame
as Rohini did earlier thinking, not just
in terms of bi laterals,
but multi laterals
and we'll have a quick go
around on this question.
And then I wanna have
time for closing thoughts
but Thomas Kingston asks, "Having
worked in human rights law
in Cambodia, and having
witnessed their governments shift
from a pro European pro US
stance to a pro China stance.
It seems to me that there's a limitation
of how human rights promotion
can be achieved through aid
especially in less democratic systems.
When China is offering support
that comes without moral
or democratic obligations,
how can this be overcome
or is it just going to
result in a bidding war?
So I think this builds on some
of what we discussed earlier
but what I appreciate
about this question is it's
from the perspective of
countries receiving assistance.
And I think you see this
playing out in many countries
in Africa as well, receiving
assistance from China
but any quick thoughts in
response to that question?
'Cause I wanted to bring
in a perspective from
the audience on China.
- So very quickly, I think the big change
since the UN intervention in Cambodia
is the incredible shift in
the sort of status prestige,
power and weight of China
is the big factor over the last 20 years.
I mean, from a British point of view
one way of thinking
about it is that in 2005
the British economy was larger
than the Chinese economy,
and the Chinese economy
is now seven times larger
than the British economy.
So that's happened just in 15 years,
the same relationship has
emerged throughout the world.
And therefore it doesn't
matter whether you're talking
about Cambodia or whether
you're talking about Zimbabwe,
the basic story of the wait
and procedure of the United States
and its allies seem to have
in the 1990s has evaporated
and being replaced by
that status of China.
- Thanks Rory, Sam I see
you wanna jump in there?
- Yeah, just briefly.
It's we shouldn't forget
that the geopolitical
competition is sometimes
a great boon to the world's peoples
especially when they can
play competing hedgemonts
off against each other.
So Melissa's story is great
but we shouldn't think the
alternative is, you know, force
and hearts and minds, which in
any way was never unconnected
from force in the Vietnam case
like the Phoenix program
and things like that.
But the broader story
of cold war development
is that there are a lot of canny actors
across the global South who understood
that they could play rivals
off against each other
to get more from each.
A great example of that
as in David Angerman
our colleague's recent
book "The Price of Aid"
about how Indian states men
basically planners and others
were able to take a lot
from both Americans and the
Soviet Union, because they knew
that their generosity
was not just innocent
but reflected these competing,
competition ideologies.
- Sam, actually just
mentioned one of our panelists
from the first of our Yale
Development Dialogue Series.
So it brings it full circle.
We only have a couple minutes left
and I wanna make sure to go back
to each of you with any closing thoughts.
Earlier, I think it was
Melissa who said we're not
being pessimistic just
realistic, but I don't know
if there's a chance to
end on a note of optimism.
I think what I'd love to hear
from each of you is kind
of back to where we began.
Why this question, why now?
And what do you hope to see?
So anything more forward-looking,
who wants to jump in?
Rory.
- Okay, I mean, I'd say
just closing thoughts.
First thing is that at the core
of a lot of what we're talking about
is basically modernization theory.
This idea from the 1950s
that there is somehow
some natural relationship
between being prosperous or
being free and being democratic.
And we are struggling now,
partly because of China, partly
because of populism with the possibility
that those things don't
go as naturally together,
as we assumed.
However, I would say, if you
want me to end with a note
of optimism and this made me touch some,
let's just say I have seen a lot
of very good small scale
programs on support human rights.
And I feel, in Pakistan
and Bangladesh, for example
that small amounts
of money supporting civil
society organizations, some very
very courageous civil
society organizations
has been extraordinary and
the counterfactual, you know
what would happen if there had
been no support whatsoever?
The human rights campaign is
working on minority communities
in Pakistan, I think is
very, very worrying indeed.
So I think it's a very good thing
for development agencies to do.
I think it's always gonna
be a very small part
of their budget.
In fact, if what you're talking about
is supporting activists on the ground
that's not gonna remotely
compare with the, you know
$20 billion that you're
putting into the other stuff.
But I think there is
still scope to do a lot.
And I think we can continue to
do it when conditions allow.
- Thanks, Rory.
I want to close with Rohini
but first Sam or Melissa,
do either of you wanna jump
in with any final thoughts
in our, we're at time,
but I wanna make sure to bring you in,
if you have something else.
- I completely agree
with what was just said.
So oftentimes in this,
in like development,
there's this big debate
between like, Oh, doing these,
like, you know big picture
things that don't like, you know
like make a dramatic
difference, you know JP
and like on a big picture versus
the smaller scale programs
where it's just easier to see
success because the number
of things that need to change
to make a dramatic difference
in kind of levels of
poverty are just huge.
And we don't really have an understanding
of how politics works
or the economics works.
And so it's not, we should
be asking those questions.
I think they're important
questions, but it's easier to see
and actually to evaluate
the successes when you look
at some of the smaller scale programs.
So I agree that like
for political reasons that some are gonna
be the main thing, but
that, that should be kind
of a central central
thing moving forward, just
because we have more hopes
when we're making small changes
and are trying to make small changes
that you know, that we're
gonna see effectiveness there.
And so I think that, you know, in addition
to having these kind of
ambitious talks about how
is everything changing and
it's a new paradigm, you know
just thinking about the
things that have worked,
even if they're small scale and, you know,
doing what we can to advocate for those.
And as I said, also to, you
know, thinking about, you know
trying to have more
appreciation for how, you know
there's policies that can actually benefit
the home countries that are
supporting this aid benefit
you know, the median voter
and also benefit people
elsewhere in the world.
- Thanks Melissa.
Sam, final thoughts from you?
- Sure, well, you know, there's
always ground for optimism.
They have to involve
seizing opportunities.
And I'd go back to the very beginning
with Rohini and Rory about
the opportunity that is open
to us now because elites in
wealthy countries are frightened
and they they've been, they
know they've been thrown out
of power in some cases,
and they're eager to figure
out what that means and change their ways.
Jake Sullivan is a great
example who remarked
in 2017 that he had the
humility of the defeated.
And I think like Lincoln,
Sullivan others are evolving
in really interesting ways.
The question is what they do next.
And I think we should
warn them against a repeat
of the cold war for some of
the reasons Melissa mentioned
but also because it doesn't
even seem to make any sense
with the new adversary
and instead push them
in ways that will make the
world's people's better off
in a series of ways.
- Rohini, back to you to close.
I thank you for putting
this topic on our agenda
for the series.
I think it's been fascinating.
What are your final thoughts?
- I think I would just echo
what all the panelists say
maybe the one thing I
would add, which is a bit
and we're looking for the US
that just given the huge role
that I would say tech
giants are playing now,
a lot what the US is going to decide to do
in terms of antitrust, in
terms of how to, you know,
get them to think about uses of data
of when it's going to be
used for surveillance.
When it's going to be is for transparency.
And it's gonna be incredibly important
in a lot of low-income
countries, but also in countries
like Hong Kong, China,
other places where, you know
what we are seeing is that
ability to, for civil society
and others to protest,
to push for human rights
depends a lot on how they are being able
to use social media right now
for coordinating protests.
- Thank you, Rohini.
Well, I know we're over time.
Thank you all for bearing with us.
I am really glad though
that we were able to go back and hear
from each of our panelists
on this very important topic.
And I think we were emerging
with more questions
that need to be answered
but we'll keep the conversation going.
We look forward to seeing all
of you in our next iteration
of the Yale Development
Dialogue Series, where again
we're bringing together
historians and practitioners
for conversations on these complex topics
as they affect low and
middle income countries.
I think this was a great example
of why there's such value in that framing.
So thank you to all of our panelists,
thank you to our attendees,
and we'll see you next time.